hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
judith jarvis thompson in her piece the
trolley problem
is going to consider a number of
different
problems not just the trolley problem
but a number of
cases some of which differ from each
other in
seemingly minor ways but which are
designed to get us to think about
what makes something wrong or more
wrong or morally permissible
and all of these revolve around some
sort of dilemma
where the life of one person is being
weighed
off against the life of five
and we as the agent have to make
some sort of decision now she's
you could say inheriting three
basic cases from philippa foote's
earlier
article the problem of abortion and the
doctrine of double effect
who she lifts a lot of these from but
she's going to transform
some of them in the process in very
interesting ways and i should point out
here
that what we nowadays typically call the
trolley problem
is in fact not philippa foote's
original formulation of the trolley
problem but
actually what is termed in this article
the bystander at the switch
sometimes with the variant of the fat
man
so that's come to take on you might say
a life of its own and to
in some respects replace the original
trolley problem
let's talk about foot's cases first so
that the trolley driver
is the person who originally
has to choose between going down the
track where there are five workmen
on the track who will not be able to get
away or taking a
a right turn which will then allow them
to go on to another section of track
where there's only one workman
they will either kill five people or one
person depending on
on what they do and there's no
you know there's no way of getting out
of this the trolley breaks are are not
working
and so it's unavoidable that you're
going to have to
have one or five people die so that's
the original
variant of that transplant has to do
with a hospital where you have a surgeon
who for the purposes of the experiment
the thought experiment
has a complete you know 100 percent
track record when it comes to
transplanting organs
the surgeon has five people who need
organ transplants and there are no
organs for them
until close to the end of the day when a
young man appears for his his checkup
and he's in great health he would be a
perfect donor
is it okay to put that
young man under anesthesia and take his
organs out
killing him in the process in order to
save
the lives of the five who need organ
transplants
then foot also a little bit later in in
the article
thompson brings this up has another case
and this is this one's called by by
thompson
hospital in the hospital
there are patients here we go there are
five patients in a hospital whose lives
could be saved by the manufacture of a
certain gas
but this will inevitably release lethal
fumes
into the room of another patient whom
for some reason
we are unable to move
so once again trading you know five
against
one and this is this is kind of an issue
so with each of these cases
thompson is going to give us some very
interesting
variations obviously bystander at the
switch we've already mentioned
in this case the trolley problem is no
longer
that you are the driver of the trolley
in this case you're actually
a bystander you're somebody who's
unrelated to the trolley company
whatsoever
and you're walking along and you see the
trolley out of control
careening towards five people on the
tracks you see that the switch
uh there's a switch that would would
shunt it off onto another track
where one person is and we see this
oftentimes drawn with you know five
people
tied to one track one person tied to
another track and a little
stick figure person there at the switch
and the question is do you
throw the switch this is as
thompson has pointed out somewhat
different than the original
trolley problem in that it really does
highlight the killing one
versus allowing five to die rather than
killing one versus killing
five she talks about two interesting
variations of this one is in talking
about moral risk
she says wait a second what if the five
workmen are actually
not workmen but mafia thugs
and they have tied the other one person
to the switch or to the track rather
and you are being in some respect
misled they actually want you to run
over the one person to save the five
who they are but in in many respects
they're not worthy of being saved it
might be better for society if you
actually did run over
the mafiosa right and that's kind of
like the villain variance that we're
going to
to look at towards the the end of this
but
the villains themselves are being put at
risk because if you
don't do it and you're like oh you know
i'm not going to intervene here it kills
them another
that's much more i would say interesting
involves a mayor
and a mayor who um gets
himself or herself in a lot of
kind of a sticky situation here we go
the five on the straight track are
regular track workmen the right hand
track is a dead end
unused in 10 years the mayor
representing the city has set out picnic
tables on it
and invited the convalescents at the
nearby city hospital to have their meals
there
guaranteeing them that no trolleys will
ever for any reason
be turned onto that track the one on the
right-hand track is a convalescent
having his lunch there
it would never have occurred to him to
do so if the mayor
had not issued his invitation and
guarantee
the mayor was out for a walk he now
stands by the switch
a dilemma there isn't it and it's
produced in part
because not just of the the
configuration
of the tracks and all that but because
that person is only there due to the
mayor
having made a promise about the safety
does the mayor then have an additional
requirement
not to throw the switch there's also the
loop
variant that that foot brings up and she
says this
actually doesn't change much of anything
instead of the tracks diverging forever
there's a loop so you're you know you're
going to either crush
one person who's a big fat person who
will stop the train
or five thin people who their combined
mass will will stop the the trolley as
well
and so in a way the loop doesn't doesn't
make that big of a difference but
foot says you know some people actually
do look at that variant differently
the fat man has drawn a lot of
interesting commentary in this case the
variant
is you don't throw a switch you
are on a bridge and there is a fat man
very fat man so fat that were he to fall
onto the tracks
he would in fact stop the trolley from
rolling
over the five other people
you see him leaning over all you'd
really need to do is
give him a little push and he would fall
perhaps screaming
frightened onto the tracks where he
would be hit by the trolley
but would stop the trolley is it morally
permissible
for you to do that this is a little bit
different than
just throwing a switch isn't it although
the question is well
why is it is it different um
she goes so far with the fat man as to
sketch out a couple other variants maybe
you don't even have to push him
maybe the railing that he's leaning on
is pretty wiggly pretty weak and all you
have to do is
nudge the railing a little bit and he
will then
fall over you're not intervening
directly you're merely taking away a
safety device
that that fat person is relying upon
is that then permissible or does that
remain
a wrong action for you to engage in
so those are a lot of interesting
trolley problems
you notice that there's differences
between them
there are myriad more sketched out by
others after thompson
let's talk about transplant though
there's another
really interesting set of considerations
that she adds to
transplant and she says that
what if instead of it just being the
same situation that
foot has sketched out these people are
sick
and they need organ transplants because
of something the surgeon did the surgeon
was badly overworked last fall
and the surgeon had to take over duties
dispensing drugs
while being particularly tired he became
careless and made the terrible mistake
of dispensing chemical acts to five of
the days patients
it works differently in different people
and some it causes lung failure another
is kidney and other heart
so these five patients who now need
parts need them because of the surgeon's
carelessness does that change the
situation
at all now he's in effect having
killed them through his his screw-up
and maybe he can set that right by
killing the young man
taking his organs and distributing them
to these other people
she says we could imagine it to have
been even worse
maybe the surgeon was badly overextended
financially
last fall he had known he was named a
beneficiary in his five patients wills
and it swept
over them him one day to give them
chemical x to kill them
now he repents and would save them if he
if he could
does that change the situation at all so
those are some pretty
fascinating sub-cases
to consider what about hospital
so in the the hospital case what we had
was
you remember philippa foot had said
you've got a
gas that's going to be manufactured but
the fumes of it would unfortunately kill
one person
even though the gas is going to save
five and she
thompson says it wouldn't be permissible
for us to manufacture that gas
but what if we have a variant all six
patients are convalescing
the five at risk are at risk not from
their ailments but from the
ceiling of the room we can prevent this
by pumping in a ceiling support
mechanism
but doing so will release lethal fumes
into the room of the sixth
is it okay to sacrifice the
sixth person to keep the ceiling from
falling in on these people she
brings up another case contrasts the
case in which lethal fumes are being
released by the heating system
in the basement of a building next door
to the hospital they're heading towards
the room of five people
we can deflect them towards the room of
one would that be permissible
are those the same as
the original hospital case or are they
vitally different
the last thing that she considers
towards the very end is well what if we
have a
villain who is involved in this what if
somebody the trolley problem is created
because somebody actually did tie people
to the tracks and says now you
deal with it right or what if they
are the person who created the hospital
situation and we can imagine
myriad more does this significantly
change the moral scope
and the possible solutions
of these problems here we don't actually
have to
say yes or no about any of these we're
just laying out the
full range of these variations that
thompson herself has thought worth
putting in front of us to think about
you